opposers a question do you guys know who
Carter pages an answer
he's a former Trump campaign foreign
policy advisor and key figure in the
Muller witch-hunt against our president
and we know it's a witch-hunt I mean
come on Hannity practically has it
shaved into the side of his head so why
is page a key figure in the
investigation the FBI says Carter page
acted as a Russian agent he says he
didn't
it's a classic he said the FBI said
situation here's what the feds say in
2013 page was recruited by Russian spies
in New York as a possible Russian asset
then in 2016 Donald Trump hires possible
Russian asset Carter page first foreign
policy Advisory Board totally not
suspicious and that summer page traveled
to Moscow which the FBI will tell you is
in Russia where page met with Putin
connected oligarchs that's whatever even
more not suspicious then after leaving
the campaign page continue to spend so
much time talking to Russians the judges
ruled that he should be wiretapped four
times in a row a fifth time and his next
wiretap was free look if Carter did
anything wrong then he was unwitting
like he says
and everyone knows nothing you do
unwittingly can be a crime like how if
you unwittingly rob a bank you can't get
arrested for a bank robbery it's it's a
colles law of did I do that
no the mainstream media wants you to
believe the FBI had every right to
surveil Carter page because he's either
treasonous or could be used as a pawn
come on does this man look like a pawn
he's definitely not the kind of guy that
say would take a script from someone he
barely knows and say whatever was on it
so imagine my surprise when Carter page
said for real that he wanted to be a
citizen journalist on this show so
Carter page stopped by so that together
we could prove how ridiculous it is that
he's being investigated at all here now
my sit-down with totally not suspicious
Carter page thank you for coming thanks
for having me Jordan it's great to be
recorded and actually know where the
microphones are yeah
in fact our sound guy didn't even have
to put a mic on you he just took other
mics off of you now Carter you are an
expert on not knowing stuff being
unwitting I have to ask you right here
and now
are you are you waiting or are you
unwitting I'm so unwitting Jordan that I
don't know exactly what I don't know yes
you seem unwitting but you do know that
your strength is not knowing if nobody
knows what you don't know then they'll
never catch you knowing what you do know
you know oh I know I know that's the
power of unwitting yeah well Wow it's
crazy to think that when your unwitting
you could be made to do almost anything
by literally anyone anywhere okay that's
I gotta tell you that's really something
you should keep an eye on Carter there
are a lot of suckers out there you're
telling me
thanks for not knowing so much Carter
page everybody
we only get the best people
[Music]